don't call it don't call it tada  don't call it catchy name for this our  planet will perish I'm still afraid so  this plan is what you would call like  long shot  well let's get stop it  [Music]  the king  that's my stuff  these guys in as well  [Music]  damn right  rated pg-13 experienced at an imax may  31st  [Music]  what we are witnessing here is the  return of tightness  [Music]  how many these things are there 17 and  Counting that mister  [Music]  mother Rodin Ghidorah oh my  they're moving like a pack they're  hunting they all respond directly to an  alpha  we stop this Ghidorah we stop them all  is there another creature that might  stand a chance against him  [Music]  our planet will perish so a week  [Applause]  plus we set Godzilla free  oh yeah Cheryl's bring him in for a beer  no this time we join the fight  run  mrs. Godzilla's well we just live in it  damn right  [Music]